- In my administration
I'm going to enforce
all laws concerning the protection
of classified information.
(audience cheering)
No one will be above the law.
- Okay, now we know the crimes
that the DOJ thinks former
President Trump committed.
When the FBI served a search warrant
on Donald Trump's Florida club,
the reaction was shock and outrage.
What records could Trump have
that would justify a raid
on the ex-president's home?
Well, now we know that reports indicate
that the FBI was sent
to retrieve documents
in part related to nuclear weapons.
(bomb exploding)
And although we don't know
what was in the dozens of boxes
removed from Mar-a-Lago,
we do know that Jay Bratt
was present for the search.
Bratt is the FBI's chief
of counterintelligence
and export control.
That probably means that
yes, Trump had information
related to nuclear weapons
or national defense.
This is a really big deal
because presidents do not
have the right to classify
or declassify records relating
to nuclear information.
We'll get into that in a second.
And now we have the benefit
of the actual warrant
that was served on Trump's estate.
So in this video we're
gonna take a deep dive
into the crimes that
former President Trump
may have violated by taking
a U-Haul full of documents
to his basement in Palm Beach.
But here's what we know so far.
On Friday morning, Trump
sent messages by Truth Social
insisting that the, quote,
"Nuclear weapons issue is a hoax."
He also suggested that
Barack Hussein Obama
had lots of nuclear information
that he had used for his library.
He also once again accused the
FBI of planting information,
and almost at the same time
he claimed that he had a standing order
to declassify all information
taken out of the White House,
which seems to run
contrary to his allegation
that the FBI planted the information
that he seemingly declassified.
It has been alleged that Mar-a-Lago
does have security cameras,
so there is a possibility
that the search might have been recorded.
Now meanwhile, Eric Trump
did what Trumps do best.
He asked people to donate
money if they're mad.
And now after a week of speculation,
we have the actual search
warrant that was served,
which is fairly unusual
because these things tend to stay sealed.
So why was it the case
that the court unsealed it?
Well, according to "The New York Times,"
the government first
tried to convince Trump
to simply return the records at issue.
When he did not comply,
the government served
Trump with a subpoena
to return the boxes.
Trump apparently only partially
responded to the subpoena,
so the DOJ decided to get a search warrant
to get the rest of the records.
"The Washington Post" has reported
the FBI sought, among other items,
classified documents
related to nuclear weapons.
Attorney General Merrick
Garland held a press conference
on Thursday where he
confirmed three things.
First, that he approved the warrant
in accordance with a memo
on political targets.
For more information about that memo,
which originated with Trump's
attorney general, Bill Barr,
check out my other video on
the Trump search warrant.
Now second, the DOJ filed a
motion with the district court
to unseal the warrant application
and the warrant itself.
That made the two documents public,
although it did not unseal
the probable cause affidavit
that gave rise to the warrant itself.
And third, the search
warrant and the return
were left with Trump's lawyers
in accordance with the federal
rules of civil procedure.
So now we can examine the
unsealed warrant itself.
According to the search warrant,
the property to be seized included, quote,
"All physical documents and
records constituting evidence,
"contraband, fruits of crime,
"or other items illegally possessed
"in violation of 18 U.S.C.
sections 793, 2071, or 1519."
So this means that Trump
is being investigated
under the following statutes:
18 U.S.C. 2071 which
prohibits the concealment,
removal, or mutilation of information,
18 U.S.C. 793 which prohibits
gathering, transmitting,
or losing defense information,
and 18 U.S.C. 1519 which
outlaws the destruction,
alteration, or falsification of records
in federal investigations.
Trump's lawyers have argued
that Trump had a right to
declassify all of these records
and that he did so before he left office.
However, none of the
three statutes require
that the information be classified
in order for it to be a crime,
and we'll talk about
that wrinkle in a second.
Trump's lawyer, Christina
Bobb, signed the receipt
listing the property that
was removed from Mar-a-Lago.
The FBI took about 20 boxes of records,
photographs, binders,
and handwritten notes.
The list starts with clemency
records related to Roger Stone
and, quote, "Info re:
the president of France."
They removed 11 sets of
classified documents.
Some of these were marked top secret
and were only allowed to be stored
in special government facilities.
It also says agents collected four sets
of top secret documents, three
sets of secret documents,
and three sets of confidential documents,
allowing the FBI to win their
game of federal gin rummy.
Now the list of documents includes records
marked "Various classified
TS/SCI documents,"
and this abbreviation refers to top secret
and sensitive compartmented information.
Now, sensitive compartmented
information is information
about certain intelligence
sources and methods
and can include information pertaining
to sensitive collection
systems, analytical processing,
and targeting, or things
that are derived from it.
Now a person can only have access to SCI
if they have a top
secret security clearance
and if they have a
need-to-know designation.
Although the president has access to SCI,
that doesn't necessarily
mean he has the authority
to remove SCI documents
and store them in his house
after he's no longer president.
And since the boxes of records
recovered from Mar-a-Lago
do seem to relate to national defense,
I turn to one of the preeminent
national security lawyers
in the country and, coincidentally,
the lawyer who is currently
litigating my federal cases
regarding John Bolton's memoir
and the inspector general misconduct
in the last administration,
Kel McClanahan.
So Kel, what could it mean if Trump has
or withheld national security information?
- Well, once national security
information is involved,
that's a completely different ball game.
And it doesn't even have to
be classified information.
The Espionage Act,
which I'm sure most of your
viewers are familiar with,
doesn't require something to be classified
before it heavily penalizes
people who take it, who hide it,
who destroy it, who keep
it in their basement.
It just requires that something be called
national defense information,
which is helpfully defined
as information related
to the national defense.
That extraordinarily broad definition
allows people to be prosecuted
under the Espionage Act
for taking information
that is not classified
as long as it has something to
do with the national defense.
And when you have classified information,
well, that triggers a different
law called 18 U.S.C. 1924
which used to be a misdemeanor
that people pled down to
for mishandling classified information,
but President Trump himself
signed a law in 2018
that made it a felony,
so that all they have to prove
is that there was classified information,
he did not store it properly,
therefore he's guilty.
It's as close to a strict liability crime
as you generally get in
the intelligence community.
- And so Kel, there are also reports
that the documents could
relate to nuclear weapons.
If that's true, how
does that change things?
- Well, the involvement of
nuclear weapons information
throws a whole new variable into the mix.
You see, what we think of
as classified information
is actually a creation
of an executive order.
That is the control of the classification
is the exclusive domain of the president
and the executive branch.
The president can classify it.
The president can declassify it.
However, nuclear weapons information
is one of the few types of information
that's controlled by a statute,
in this case the Atomic Energy Act,
and the statute says that this information
cannot be released or disseminated
without going through
a certain set of steps,
and that if not within
the exclusive control
of the president.
Therefore, even if Trump had said
that he declassified this information
before he took it home with
him, that wouldn't be enough.
He would have declassified it
for the purposes of the executive order,
but he would still be bound
by the Atomic Energy Act
which carries its own criminal penalties.
- Thanks a lot, Kel.
Kel runs the National Security Counselor
and does great work,
including legal attempts to
recover the Secret Service
and DHS leadership text messages
that were illegally deleted last year
that you've no doubt
read about in the news,
and a tax deductible donation
to the NSC would go a long way
since they're handling many cases,
including my own, pro bono.
So there's a link to that
down in the description.
So that's the information and documents
that are at issue in this investigation,
but let's look at the actual crimes
that are being investigated.
The first is 18 U.S.C. 1519,
the destruction, alteration,
or falsification of records
in federal investigations.
It states, quote, "Whoever
knowingly alters, destroys,
"mutilates, conceals,
covers up, falsifies,
"or makes a false entry
in any record, document,
"or tangible object with the
intent to impede, obstruct,
"or influence the investigation
"or proper administration of any matter
"within the jurisdiction
of any department or agency
"of the United States shall
be fined under this title,
"imprisoned not more
than 20 years, or both."
So in other words, to convict
a defendant of obstruction
under section 1519, the
government has to prove
each of the following elements.
First, that the defendant
knowingly altered,
destroyed, concealed, or falsified
a record, document, or tangible object.
And second, the defendant acted
with the intent to impede,
obstruct, or influence an actual
or contemplated investigation of a matter
within the jurisdiction of an
agency of the United States.
Now, the government doesn't have to prove
the defendant's sole or
even primary intention
was to obstruct justice
as long as the government
proves beyond a reasonable doubt
that one of the defendant's intentions
was to obstruct justice.
But that takes us to 8 U.S.C. 2071
which prohibits the willful
concealment, destruction,
or removal of federal documents.
To establish a violation
of this provision,
The government must prove, one,
an individual concealed,
removed, or destroyed a record
or attempted to do so or took
and carried away a record
with the intent to do so,
the record was filed or
deposited in a public office
of the United States,
and the individual acted
willfully and unlawfully.
Now, note that this is
a specific intent crime
that requires a person
to have had an intention
to destroy or remove the records
in violation of these laws.
And is often the case with
these specific intent crimes,
Trump might be able to
argue that he didn't know
he wasn't allowed to remove
the documents or destroy them,
although there's certainly evidence
that he was repeatedly told
he was violating the law
with the way that he handled records.
"The Washington Post" reported
that two of Trump's
former chiefs of staff,
Reince Priebus and John Kelly,
and former White House Counsel Don McGahn,
warned him about the
Presidential Records Act.
When it comes to a potential
violation of 18 U.S.C. 2071,
there is an additional wrinkle
because that section
ostensibly prohibits someone
from running from office.
Now I take a deep dive into
that language, the case law,
and the potential repercussions
for former President Trump
in a video that's exclusive to Nebula
that I'll talk about in a little while.
But that takes us to 18 U.S.C. 793
which concerns the
gathering, transmitting,
or losing defense information.
Section 793 is known as the Espionage Act
which covers the unlawful retention
of defense-related information
which could harm the
United States or an ally.
Now, the Espionage Act
is a bit of a misnomer.
It's not really, or most of
it is not about espionage.
It's really about state secrets.
Now, section 793 D makes it
a crime for anyone, quote,
"Lawfully having possession
of, access to, control over,
"or being entrusted with any
of a range of tangible items
"or information relating
to the national defense
"which information the
possessor has reason to believe
"could be used to the
injury of the United States
"or to the advantage
of any foreign nation,
"willfully communicates,
delivers, transmits,
"or causes or attempts the same
"to any person not entitled to receive it,
"or willfully retains the
same and fails to deliver it
"on demand to the officer or
employee of the United States
"entitled to receive it."
In other words, it's a crime
to leak national security information.
Section 793 F makes it a
crime for government officials
who have lawful possession of
such materials to remove them
or disclose them to third parties
who are unauthorized to receive them.
To be guilty of this offense,
the person has to have
disclosed the information
due to their own gross negligence
or because of their failure to report
the information lost or stolen.
But the Espionage Act is not
limited to just those people
who wrongfully disclose
national defense information.
Section 793 E also says
it applies to anyone
who knowingly disseminates, distributes,
or even retains national
defense information
without immediately returning the material
to the government officer
authorized to possess it.
In other words, the text of
the act draws no distinction
between the leaker, the
recipient of the leak,
or the 100th person to
redistribute, retransmit,
or even retain the national
defense information
that, by that point, is
already in the public domain.
So basically the entire
staff of Mar-a-Lago
should probably lawyer up at this point.
And if the person who is
charged under the act knows
or has reason to believe
that the information
in their possession relates
to the national defense
and could be used to
injure the United States
or benefit a foreign power,
that person's violating
the act's plain language
regardless of their specific intent.
So that means that almost
anyone in the chain
could be prosecuted under this section,
the leaker, who in this case
would be the ex-president,
his son, son-in-law, a journalist,
or even one of Trump's lawyers.
Now there is one crime
that isn't mentioned
in the search warrant,
and that is a violation of
the Presidential Records Act,
and there's a very good reason
for why the PRA is not
mentioned in the search warrant.
So let's talk about a president
and former president's
responsibility under the PRA.
Section 2203 of the
act gives the president
the responsibility of
identifying preserving records
during the administration
and requires the president
to take all such steps
as may be necessary to
preserve presidential records.
However, a president
may also destroy records
that the president decides, quote,
"No longer have
administrative, historical,
"informational, or evidentiary value."
Before destroying records,
the president must ask the
archivist for their opinion.
Although the archivist
can give an opinion,
the person can't stop the president
from making their own call.
And if the archivist does not sign off
on the president's determination,
congressional subcommittees are notified,
but it's unclear what
Congress can actually do
during such a dispute.
The statute is murky and vague,
which brings up the most
important point about the PRA.
It lacks a real enforcement mechanism.
Although a president is not
supposed to rip up records,
shred them, or flush them down the toilet,
the PRA is at most a
statement of best practices
like an honor system.
This was illustrated
early in Trump's tenure
when CREW challenged Trump's
record keeping practices
by suing him under the PRA.
CREW alleged that Trump deleted tweets
in violation of the PRA
and that the White
House's use of encrypted
and auto-deleting messages
hindered the ability
of federal agencies to
perform their duties.
The lawsuit sought a court order
compelling the president to
stop auto deleting messages
and preserve them under the PRA,
but the DC circuit
dismissed CREW's lawsuit
interpreting the president's
record-keeping duties narrowly.
The court held that mandamus
relief was only available
under extraordinary circumstances
and that a president's
record-keeping duties under the PRA
are to discretionary to be
enforced by court order.
Although courts can
review the classification
of existing records,
a court can't stop the
president from acting.
In other words, the court held
it could not tell the president
to create and preserve particular records.
However, courts have
been willing to enforce
some modest limits on what
White House officials can do
with records that have
already been created.
CREW successfully sued Dick
Cheney for failure to classify
some documents as presidential records.
A district court also
invalidated an agreement
between President H.W. Bush
and the National Archives
that would've conferred complete control
of presidential records on the president
after he left office.
Although citizens don't have
a right to enforce the PRA,
the Department of Justice
arguably does have a mandate
to enforce the PRA in some circumstances.
CREW and the National Security Archive
wrote to FBI director Chris
Wray and AG Merrick Garland
and requested that they investigate
whether former President
Trump violated criminal laws
by willfully destroying and mutilating
his presidential records while in office.
The National Archives also requested
that the Department of Justice
undertake an investigation.
But there are a number
of criminal statutes
that make removal and destruction
of federal property a crime.
It is generally illegal to remove property
from the White House.
For example, in 2001, Bill
Clinton staffers removed
the W key from West Wing keyboards
right before George W.
Bush was inaugurated.
This prank was actually theft,
and the general accounting
office interviewed
over 100 government employees
about the theft of the Ws.
So if the government
decides to charge Trump
with crimes related to these documents,
what are Trump's defenses here?
Well, the first would
probably be declassification.
Trump's lawyers say
that he had declassified
the documents at issue.
Now, presidents do have
broad plenary power
to classify and declassify documents.
That power stems from their
position as commander-in-chief.
The president can delegate this authority,
they can exercise it themselves,
or they can order the release
of classified documents
after a certain period of time.
And as far as we know, Barack
Obama was the last president
to issue an order on
classified information.
Under Obama's Executive Order 13526,
original classification authorities,
like the heads of various
departments and agencies,
were allowed to classify
and declassify information
owned by their organizations.
That means that
departments might authorize
the disclosure of information to someone
with the proper security clearance.
And this executive order
has not been rescinded
and federal agencies
are still following it.
However, future and following presidents,
like Trump and Biden,
are under no obligation to
follow Obama's executive order.
They can tweak the order, issue their own,
or simply handle things
in an ad hoc manner.
And Trump's approach to
classified information
could probably be
described as freewheeling.
And after Trump lost the 2020 election,
Donald Trump Jr. tweeted
that his dad should, quote,
"Declassify everything.
"We can't let the bad
actors get away with it."
Could Trump have declassified everything?
- I think deepen your heart
you already know the answer to that.
- Well, technically, yes, the
president does have the power
to declassify every document
that the U.S. government holds,
but then that information would be public
and you could FOIA that
information and release it.
And Trump's defenders in
Congress held a press conference
to explain that not
everything that is classified
is totally classified,
and in some ways what they're saying
actually does make sense.
The government tends to
overclassify records,
and arguably a lot more information
should be available to the public.
Transparency in government
is generally a good thing,
but in this case we may be talking about
some extremely sensitive
top secret information,
information that may
relate to nuclear weapons.
And this gets us to one
of the main exceptions
about the president's
declassification powers
which is that the president
doesn't fully control
information about nuclear weapons.
The Atomic Energy Act
regulates information
about nuclear weapons and nuclear energy.
Under the act, restricted data
and formally restricted data
are top secret information,
and the act defines restricted data
as all data concerning
the design, manufacturer,
or utilization of atomic weapons,
the production of
special nuclear material,
and the use of special nuclear material
in the production of energy.
Now, nuclear information is placed
in the formally restricted data category
after the Department of Energy
and the Department of Defense
jointly determine that
it relates primarily
to the military utilization
of atomic weapons.
Now, the president also lacks
control over information
related to U.S. and foreign
intelligence operations.
The Intelligence Identities
Protection Act protects
the identity of covert U.S.
intelligence operatives.
Their identities and
other intelligence sources
are protected by statute
and the president cannot reveal them
without breaking federal law.
And there's also another exception
to the president's declassification power
which should be completely obvious.
Former presidents don't
have the legal authority
to declassify records
after they leave office.
But at base, as noted earlier,
declassifying the documents
is only one of the hurdles
since a lot of the statutes at issue here
do not turn on whether the
information is classified.
That's completely unrelated.
We also don't know if Trump
followed the procedure
for declassifying the documents.
He can't just think
declassification in his head
while president and the
documents are declassified.
The lawyers at Just Security
summarize the process
for declassification like this:
"Classified documents have
classification markings
"in the header and footer of each page
"indicating the level of classification
"for the document as a whole.
"Furthermore, classified
records have cover sheets
"that specifically indicate
when the record was classified,
"by whom, and under what authority,
"as well as when the
classification expires.
"If Trump did in fact
order the declassification,
"he still needed to make sure his staff
"took the necessary next steps
"to modify the classification
markings on the documents
"before he could actually
handle and store the records
"as a private citizen as
if they were unclassified.
"Under security classification rules,
"a classification marking on
a document has to be treated
"as valid and binding unless and until
"a subsequent marking replaces it.
"Appropriate government
staffers would've needed
"to cross out the classification markings
"in the headers and footers
and stamped 'declassified'
"on the record noting when
it was declassified, by whom,
"and under what authority.
"Since that does not
appear to have been done
"with the classified documents
reportedly identified
"to date, the documents remain classified
"and had to be treated as classified
"for handling and storage purposes."
It's probably worth noting that ignorance
is not gonna be a defense here
because reportedly the FBI
and DOJ met with Trump several
times, issued a subpoena,
and not all of the
documents were given back.
And even the fact that
some of the documents
were given back initially
shows that they know how to
handle classified documents
and agree that some of these documents
needed to be returned to the government.
That being said, Trump might
have a First Amendment defense.
The Supreme Court does
recognize that in some cases
the public's interest
in receiving information
can outweigh the government's
interest in keeping it secret.
However, when evaluating
First Amendment concerns
the court gives more leeway to reporters
who lawfully obtain government documents
than they do to government officials.
And, you know, when you're
talking about classified
and defense information
or information related
to nuclear documents,
security interests are
probably going to outweigh
those First Amendment concerns.
So will this be the thing that brings down
the former president?
It's hard to say, but a
lot of people have noticed
that a violation of section
2071 can carry with it
a penalty of being barred from office.
Could that be used to prevent
Trump from running again?
Well, I have an entire
separate video over on Nebula,
exclusive to Nebula,
which is today's sponsor
along with Curiosity Stream,
because on Nebula my videos
always come out early
with zero ads,
and I release exclusive
content like this all the time
like this entire video on whether Trump
can be barred from office,
a video on Alex Jones's testimony,
whether it amounts to perjury or not,
and my first full-length
documentary "Bad Law Words Good,"
which is honestly hilarious.
I'm really proud of it.
All of this exclusive content
is available only on Nebula
which you can get for free
with Curiosity Stream.
Nebula is creator-owned
and creator-operated
and there's exclusive new content
released multiple times every day
by the Internet's best
educational creators.
And by the way, we've been
developing Nebula like crazy.
Nebula now has apps for
iOS, Android, Apple TV,
Roku, Fire TV, and Android TV.
And it was recently nominated
for its first Streamy Award.
My fellow creators and I
really care about Nebula,
and we're thrilled to be
partnering with Curiosity Stream
because they're the go-to source
for the best documentaries
and long-form educational
content on the internet.
They even have an entire section devoted
to unsolved mysteries and crime.
So if you like my videos,
you'll love the thousands of
titles on Curiosity Stream.
And the best way to get access to Nebula
and all of the incredible content
is through the amazing Curiosity
Stream-Nebula bundle deal
with its current sales price
of less than $15 per year
to get full access to both sites.
And to be clear, that Nebula
subscription is not a trial.
It's free for as long as you're
a Curiosity Stream member.
There just isn't a
better deal in streaming
where you get two great streaming sites
with content that you'll
actually watch and enjoy
for less than $15 a year
at the current sales price.
So to get Curiosity Stream and Nebula
for less than $15 per year,
just click on the link
that's on screen right now
or down in the description.
It's a great way to
support educational content
and get tons of exclusive
content that you'll love.
So for less than $15 per year,
click on the link that's
on screen right now
or down in the description.
And after that, click on this playlist
for more LegalEagle videos.
So click on this playlist
or I'll see you in court.